welcome back to the technical guide for
startups a video series where we help
startups to start build and grow their
businesses successfully and sustainably
on Google cloud my name is Matteo and
I'm a customer engineer here at Google
Cloud I'm here with you today to
introduce you to looker how this
technology works and the value it can
bring to your organization
after helping you with starting your
journey to the cloud and optimizing your
deployments in the start and build
Series today we're kicking off the grow
Series where we will help you meet the
needs of new customers and expand to New
Markets
we are right at the beginning of your
journey to grow your business on Google
cloud and today we want to show you how
to become a data driven Company by
uncovering insights with looker
here is what we will cover today first
we will look at the different products
included in the Luger family such as
lucar Luca studio and Luca Studio Pro
then we will dive deeper into what Luca
really is what traditional bi looked
like and how looker solves the problems
that traditional bi systems cause
further we will cover looker's
architecture and how looker actually
works with a technical demo focus on
Luca's main features namely lucamel
explorers and dashboards we will then
conclude by showing you how startup
customers are successfully utilizing
looker to uncover insights from their
data
here's what Luca really is in a nutshell
Lookers Google's unified intelligent and
open bi platform and here I would like
to highlight a few of the features that
make Luca special first of all it's
Universal semantic layer which enables
complex data to be simplified for end
users in curated catalogs with
predefined business metrics and built-in
data Transformations secondly its API
connectivity meaning that just about
anything that you can do with the looker
application you can also do through API
for example you can provision new user
accounts run queries or schedule reports
Luca also has a powerful integration
with ML and AI tools such as bigquery ml
but also jupyter notebooks if you would
like to build your custom models on your
data lastly through self-service
visualizations you can Empower all your
employees to extract insights from your
data and improve your company-wide
decision making processes
the Luca product family includes looker
Luca studio and Luca Studio Pro Lucas
studio is a self-service visualization
tool where you can create dashboards
directly from your spreadsheets here no
centralized data model is required and
you can import data from a variety of
sources and start working with your data
in a few minutes Additionally you can
collaborate with your colleagues and
share your dashboards with whoever you
would like looker on the other hand is
our multi-cloud data platform that gives
you governance of your data at scale it
allows you to explore your data on a
universal semantic layer
Lucas studio and Luker work hand in hand
to provide a complete unified and
comprehensive platform for self-service
and centralized business intelligence to
help you work with your data
before diving into looker I would like
to quickly focus on local Studio Pro the
paid version of looker Studio our
self-serve business intelligence
reporting tool the solution will gain
increasing importance within the looker
ecosystem and on top of allowing you to
visually analyze data and design
impactful reports it will give you an
enhanced visibility of your data across
your organization through an integration
with dataplex
will give you an improved team
collaboration experience with Team
workspaces providing better access and
content management functionalities
and it will give you access to 24 7
support channels in a 99.9 availability
SLA
and let us now dive deeper into how lucr
innovates the business intelligence
landscape with traditional business
intelligence Tools in order to create a
dashboard for a specific business
purpose it is usually necessary to First
find the right data amongst the data
available to the company as data sits in
different sources data analysts need to
extract the data by using connectors or
writing SQL queries then the data is
aggregated into sealed workbooks which
represent different subsets of the
overall data finally it is visualized
into a variety of different dashboards
and reports that are then consumed by
business users this causes two main
issues firstly if new information has to
be added to the report we need to go
back to the data analyst every time as
you might imagine this process can
become a bottleneck as it is rather time
consuming for a data analyst to
accommodate the request of such a high
number of stakeholders secondly in case
we want to update or create a new metric
data analysts need to go back into every
report or workbook to update the metric
creating data chaos and severe
inconsistencies across dashboards
looker solves both problems with Luca
you can have the trustworthiness that
comes with everyone using standardized
definitions of your business metrics
without losing the ability for people to
self-serve to answer their own questions
with data
fundamentally Luca will enable everyone
to make better decisions with data and
this is only going to happen if everyone
can ask questions on the data and get
reliable and correct answers without
bottlenecks or chaos
let's now take a look at the different
components and mechanisms that make
Lookers such a unique business
intelligence platform at its core
Lookers in database architecture allows
customers to avoid having to extract
data every time they need to build a
report instead data is queried directly
from the underlying database avoiding
any unnecessary movement of data
secondly Luca will speak SQL to your
database but everything will first go
through a code-based semantic modeling
layer called Luke ml this will
effectively work as a single source of
truth that avoids any inconsistencies in
your data and allows you to Define
standard metrics across your business
and maintain them from a single location
last but not least lucra is cloud native
and fully web-based everything is hosted
and maintained by looker thanks to its
API first approach lucr allows users to
push data to business applications or
automate workflows Based on data
for example if your marketing campaign
is not performing as planned and look at
the text that your conversion rate is
below a certain thresholds you can
configure it as such that your campaign
is stopped automatically pretty cool
note
here's how lucr changes the bi scene
looker connects directly to your SQL
database giving you a complete picture
of your company data Luca provides any
users with a business intelligence tool
and interactive dashboards which can be
easily updated by non-technical users it
allows you to integrate your data to
third-party tools using dynamic alerting
or exporting your customer segment to
your marketing tool finally you can
build with looker by productizing your
data and metrics into third-party
software
Lou will now run you through a demo to
show you how to go from database to
insights focusing on looker's three main
features Luke ml explorers and
dashboards hi everyone
Lou I'm a customer engineer from Google
Cloud today I'm going to show you how to
deploy Luca in your organization by
generating and customizing a reusable
data model
exploring the data through that model
and creating a Luca dashboard
first step is to connect Luca to your
database
Luca work with real-time data we do not
store or extract data in local the data
stay in the database
I'm going to develop and select manage
look ml project
and from here I'm going to create a
brand new project let's call this
e-commerce since it's an e-commerce data
set
a project is something that is going to
stick with us my co-worker and I are
able to build business logic into that
which allow us to collaborate on
once the project is created the first
step is to create a view file click
create view from table I will need to
select the database connection and the
tables that I will need
I'm going to use the database called
Ecom and select the table
inventory items
and all the items and click create views
Luca is now scanning through and
generating all the columns that exist in
this table
for example
we can see an ID column in the order
items table
it also found the column called created
and delivered
and automatically broke it into
different time frames
these are going to be very flexible for
me to use
a dimension is a column coming straight
from the database like sales price
Dimension and measures are defined in
Luca like this average sale price
this is the unique location where the
metrics are defined
there are two reasons why we Define
metric like this number one this is how
it enforce local single source of juice
everyone will be using the same
definition of the metric number two this
makes look very scalable to update a
metric you update here and it will be
updated everywhere in every dashboard
which is using the metric
before I can explore this data I will
firstly need to create a model file
[Music]
first added the connection name to Luca
private demo
then specify the table that I want to
explore in this case it will be other
items
now we are good to go let's start with
our first explore
I want to know what the average sales
price is so what I need to do is just to
click the average sales price on the
left
and click run
it looks great but I hope to format it
to US dollar
so I'm going back to other items view
file
and added the average sales price
let's now go back to explore page and
refresh the web page
with that I get my average sales price
in US dollar
now comes to the question what if I need
to use the information from other tables
we will firstly need to let Luca know
how these two table join together in the
model file
here I specify the view name which is
inventory items it will join the author
items using the key Item ID
in the inventory table we have the
information of product course
and in the order items table we have the
information about the sales price
now to get the gross margin and from
there using the stamp of gross merging
to calculate the total gross margin I
can simply do a calculation like this
with that I'm going to refresh the
explore page
remove the current filters
and explore the total gross margin
I'm going to click created date from the
inventory table
and total gross margin from the order
items table
click run
from here I want to filter the date to
the past 30 days and click run again
with that I got the total gross margin
for the past 30 days
as we saw lucamel will support your
scalability needs as your company grows
it will serve as a single source of
Truth for all your company data and
metrics additionally any changes to
business logic are always tracked thanks
to its integration to GitHub in the next
part Lou will show you how non-technical
people will use a self-service layer to
explore data
let me explain what happened in this
explore page anytime users select metric
on the left Luca is writing SQL
automatically on behalf of the user when
you press the red button Luca is sending
this query to the database which
understands exactly what was requested
and Returns the results
free up a huge amount of time for your
data analysts who will not need to
constantly write SQL queries again and
again
at the same time you are sure that the
result are consistent because all the
metrics are defined in one location
once you have created your visualization
you can do three different things
number one you can share it with a link
as Luca is being fully web-based the
user you share it with will have the
same ways with the same filters number
two you can save it as a new dashboard
[Music]
and here you are I have just created a
new dashboard on my own without having
to go to a technical person
the third thing I can do is to schedule
this report and send the data to a third
party tool
through the explore function business
users can get answers to business
questions in seconds without any
technical knowledge required data
analysts can save substantial amount of
time and focus on valid ad activities
finally your numbers and results are
consistent across the entire
organization as metrics are defined and
accessed from a single location
in part 3 we will cover a few examples
about the dashboard
in part 2 we show you how to Simply
create a dashboard to show total gross
merging for the past 30 days let's take
a look at the dashboard page and have a
better understanding on what else we can
do
as Luca has access to all the data that
sits in your database which means I can
see every transaction
and not only can I see this
transactional data I can also take
action on it
by clicking average order sales price
I'm able to see the raw data and send
emails straight from Lucan
all the data is in real time Luca does
not store any data so I can also set
alerts if any metric exceeds certain
threshold such as if average sales price
is less than 25 and specify the filters
allows are configured to send their
specified recipients notification to
email or select when the alerts
conditions are met or exit
finally we saw the power of lucr
dashboards which allow users to browse
data in real time Define metrics once
and use conditional alerts to Monitor
kpi and take action accordingly and
finally access underline transactional
data and really understand the why
behind the metrics they see before
concluding we would like to show you how
one of our customers operating in the
insurance industry simply business
transform the insurance experience with
docker
simply business grew to over 700
employees in the UK and USA it faced a
few challenges as it did not have a
centralized data platform it had
information silos which led to
inconsistent reporting and mistrusting
data which caused delaying decision
making
by integrating Luca in its day-to-day
operations simply business was able to
get real-time access to data and
accelerate its reporting processes
transform their customer experience by
speeding up their contact center
analytics and finally Implement a
centralized analytics Hub to manage your
business metrics to conclude today we
saw how lucr can enable your
organization to unlock data for every
employee by being your trusted data
platform enabling you to make informed
decisions and help you deliver Pleasant
data experiences to your organization
in the description below we have
compiled a few resources you could use
to get started with Luca we really hope
this video has been informative and do
not wait anymore and start exploring
with looker to find the true power in
your data but first do not forget to
subscribe to our YouTube channel and
stay tuned for our next video on our
sustainability strategy to help you
understand how Google Cloud can support
you and your company on your
sustainability Journey
[Music]